oh man this is a tough day for me
it was tough waking up this morning and
finding the reason to go on the Ravens
the Ravens lost yesterday they law my
Baltimore Ravens lost on a missed extra
point on a missed extra point in the
final seconds of the game they got the
most accurate field goal kicker in the
history of the league he's never missed
an extra point in his entire career
including College like 300 straight made
extra point kicks and this is the one
that he decides to miss and then we lost
the game and to make matters worse you
know after the game last night I was
sitting in the living room in a state of
deep shock and and misery and in a bit
of a existential crisis asking myself
what's the point of life what's the
point of anything and then my my
daughter comes in and she she says what
what's the matter daddy are you sad you
look sad and I said I said yes I'm very
sad the Ravens lost on a missed extra
point at the end of the game and she
said what's an extra point and I said
well it's the field goal that you kick
after a touchdown if you're not gonna go
for two and she said what's a field goal
what's a touchdown what's going for two
and I said please stop interrogating me
can't you see that I'm that I'm
traumatized here and she said well are
you gonna cry daddy and I said yes I
might cry I might cry and she said well
daddies don't cry no daddies don't cry
and I said you're right daddies don't
cry
except when their football team loses on
a missed extra point at the very end of
the game then they might cry and then
she said and I'm not gonna quote her
exactly okay
she said that's silly daddy that's silly
to cry over football
football is silly and so what was I
gonna do I call the police on her had
her carted away which is not the kind of
thing that you want to ever it's not a
decision you ever want to make as a
parent especially when your daughter is
five years old but what else was I going
to do she's she's a she's gonna go
around saying things like that she's a
threat to society all right but I will
in a in an act of great courage and
resilience I will try to soldier on and
move on somehow with my
all right what I want to talk about the
the film about Kermit Gosnell has
entered its its second week at the box
office it entered its second week this
past weekend and despite only showing on
600 or so theaters in its first week and
despite the limited budget and despite
being ignored by the media it completely
it managed to crack the top ten in its
first week top ten at the box office
which is extremely impressive okay to
get into the top ten given the situation
now keep this in mind when it comes to
box office totals and you hear about you
know you hear about a movie like like
Avengers is number one at the box office
for ten straight weeks or whatever well
keep in mind that movies like The
Avengers they open on four thousand
screens and they have hundreds of
millions of dollars of marketing and
merchandise I mean you can't avoid them
you know for six months leading up to
the movie coming out the movies
everywhere everywhere you go just you
see it you see previews of commercials
and merchandise and then it's on every
single screen across the universe and so
a movie like that it has to be number
it's got to be number one for two months
if it's not that it's a massive failure
because the movies the movie studios pay
a lot of money to manufacture interest
and to get the movies out there and so
that's why in my mind there's nothing
particularly impressive about a
massively hyped massively expensive
movie showing on four thousand screens
with 15 showings apiece ending up number
one at the box office but that's why I'm
never you know every time there's a new
Marvel movie or Star Wars and everyone's
like oh it's the number one movie in
history again we of course number one
that you know movie tickets now cost
eighty seven dollars as opposed to as
opposed to in the 90s and there were
five dollars and the movie studio is
paying millions of dollars to brainwash
us into seeing the the freaking thing so
of course of course it's number one
that's not a present but a movie like
like Gosnell with no press very little
marketing on a few screens in a small
budget well cracking a million dollars
and the top
in that case is huge yet as the daily
wire reported this weekend the film was
dropped again only at second week it was
dropped from almost 200 screens of the
of the only 600 it was showing on in its
second week this is a top 10 movie that
was dropped in its second week and
dropped from theaters with 20 or 30
screens where it was in the top 10 among
all those films and many of those
theaters dropped it after one week which
is unprecedented which is it's just it's
unheard of despite what anyone might
want to say to try to you'll come up
with a rationale this is unheard of this
doesn't this doesn't have even if a
movie performs really poorly in its
first week it's pretty rare for it to be
dropped after one week usually at least
gets one other week but to be a top 10
movie and then get dropped after after
seven days in the theater it's just it's
ridiculous let me read a little bit of
story from The Daily wire it says
according to John Sullivan the film's
marketing director who also served as a
producer the drop cannot be written off
as a mere coincidence or quote business
as usual he says he told the Daily wire
I can tell you from my experience in 15
years of releasing movies independently
we're in uncharted territories it is an
impacted fall no doubt about it but the
fact that we've been dropped from
theaters where the movie is the number
six or number nine movie is just
something you don't see it's hard not to
believe it isn't about the content of
the movie
we have theaters that are dropping on
the movie that are that are top theaters
that are performing very well we've been
the number six in a 15 plex theater and
it gets dropped this week we've been
number nine in a 30 Plex and we're
getting dropped this week so that's it's
the number nine movie out of 30 and they
drop it there are about 15 I'm 15
theaters like that where typically you
would not get dropped he says I do
recognize it's a crowded market
marketplace because Halloween is is a
you know going to be a huge opening but
it's very odd to me that you're within
the top ten and you're getting dropped
out of a movie house the filmmakers have
also received varying reports of
theaters actively preventing customers
from buying a ticket by not advertising
the film or declaring it sold out
for capacity is reached while some of
those situations may be the result of
human error Sullivan says the apparent
blackballing is too consistent to be
ignored and then he goes on to talk
about how it's unprecedented on a public
statement of Facebook the film's
producer said he had received worrying
reports from across the country regret
regarding customers inability to buy
tickets and then he talks about some
stories of people that you know even in
the theaters where it's being shown
they're being prevented or it's being
made difficult to buy tickets to the
movie now one of the ways that you know
this isn't all a coincidence is because
this is how this is just totally in
keeping with how the Gosnell story has
been treated and how the Gosnell movie
has been treated and and the actual
event itself before them but I'm
speaking of the you know staying on the
movie for just a minute we should also
mention that hardly any media outlets
even bothered to review the movie Rotten
Tomatoes which is a site that compiles
movie reviews so you could go and see
you know get a get kind of an aggregated
percentage score on how a good movie is
even though the percentages are
oftentimes very misleading but it could
only find 10 reviews for Gosnell across
the entire internet it could find it
could find 10 reviews by comparison the
Halloween movie which came out this
weekend has over 200 reviews so that's
200 reviews 210 now obviously Gosnell
isn't as big as a movie as Halloween
despite being scarier and having a more
evil villain but and a more prolific
killer also at the core of the movie but
still that disparity is ridiculous only
10 reviews whereas you know a movie will
typically get 100 150 200 or more that
is not a coincidence as the marketing
director of the film pointed out this is
not a coincidence there is an active
decision being made to ignore this movie
to blackball this movie to censor this
movie now can it be justified on any
kind of practical level
as I said the movie has been a success
in spite of all this obviously showing
that there's intense interest in the
movie the average movie if it's only
playing on 600 theaters and it's not
getting any press and there's hardly any
marketing the average movie like that is
just it's not it's going to make a few
it's gonna make a few thousand dollars
and then it's gonna be gone but as I
said to pull in a million get into the
top ten that shows that there is
enormous interest in the movie so you
can't justify it on that you can't say
well of course it's being ignored it's
just a you know it's a movie nobody
cares about people do care about it and
then the story you can't say well the
story doesn't matter I mean you know
it's it's I mean it's it's it's a it's
an irrelevant story that's what no the
story is very dramatic very relevant
very current Gosnell is as the tagline
of the movie correctly points out
Gosnell is the worst serial killer in
american history now to recap very
briefly in case you've forgotten about
Gosnell or if you've never heard about
him in the first place
the abortionist was was officially
charged in 2013 with the murders of
seven infants and one woman but the
total body count is is much higher than
that Gosnell used scissors to sever the
spinal cords of hundreds of live babies
hundreds maybe even more maybe thousands
one employee of the of the clinic in
Philadelphia testified that she
personally witnessed this procedure
snipping as Gosnell called it at least
30 times so although he was although he
was only charged only charged with
murdering seven infants as if that's not
bad enough you've got just one witness
who says well I saw it happen 30 times
in some cases she was given the child's
severed feet or any or another severed
body part to put in a jar and keep as a
trophy to be clear children were I just
think this needs to be emphasized
children were born alive outside the
womb
fully formed these are born infants and
then they were decapitated that's what
was going on hundreds and hundreds of
times over the course of 30 years
there's a reason why this clinic was
dubbed the house of horrors because it's
not a cliche it really it really was
there were quoting from from a one
medical student who saw it he said there
were fetuses and blood all over the
place
you could another nurse reports that you
could literally hear the screams of
children who were born alive and then
butchered so if you can imagine this
this this butcher shop where there's
bloodstains on the walls body parts in
jars and buckets and and the screams of
children being murdered I mean it's just
carcasses and body parts were stored in
shoeboxes water jugs break room
refrigerators and this is to say nothing
of the of the unsanitary medical
equipment which caused disease and
infection in the patient patients one
woman had to go to a hospital and and
have part of her intestine removed after
contracting an infection from from
Gosnell's clinic and then another woman
died at least one woman died as a result
of this of this malpractice now the
point is this is a significant story
that deserves to be told that should be
told it's the kind of story that if it
were happening in any other profession
any other alleged medical field there
would have been five movies and two TV
specials about it already I mean if you
could imagine if you could imagine an
orthodontist or or a pediatrician
murdering hundreds of patients it would
be the biggest story in the country and
film adaptations would come almost
immediately that's the way it would be
treated but this because it's an
abortionist has always been treated as a
non-story one Washington Post reporter
infamously said that gozman Gosnell
systematic slaughter of infants over the
course of 30 years is just a local
crime story that's how she went when
when asked to justify her papers
decision to ignore the story she said
well sir just a local crime story
hundreds of dead babies local crime
story so and to put that in context by
the way this is not long before Ferguson
where you had one you know one one
teenager that was shot by a police
officer and what turned out to be a
totally justified shooting but that you
know what one person being killed that
that wasn't treated as a local crime
story nobody said that was local crime
the Washington Post was all over that
yet hundreds of babies being killed in a
major American city in a in an alleged
medical facility over the course of 30
years that's just local crime so why is
this happening why did the media ignore
why does it still ignore the Gosnell
case why does the left in general treat
this like it never happened why are they
so terrified of Gosnell that's the
question and I think there are three
pretty obvious reasons that we'll get
into now so why is this being ignored
number one I think the Gosnell case
really explodes one of the most common
pro-abortion talking points which is
namely that the prohibition of abortion
will lead if you prohibit abortion
that's gonna lead to horrific and
unsanitary back-alley abortions and so
forth now that's what we're told
you know we're told well you can't get
rid of abortion because then it's gonna
be this it's gonna be a horror show or
there's women you know getting abortions
and these unsanitary conditions unsafe
conditions as as if it's possible to
safely as if as if it's ever possible to
have a safe abortion which of course it
isn't by definition because by
definition in every abortion in every
successful abortion that's ever been
performed
at least one human being has been killed
so there's no such thing as a safe
abortion but those kinds of abortions
that the pro board people worry about
those kinds of abortions happened at
Gosnell's clinic for 30 years
even though abortion is legal and I
think a person who takes note of that
fect who says well hold on this is
exactly the kind of abortion that I
thought we were preventing by having
abortion legal and so I think if you
noticed that and then if you get really
curious and you start investigating and
you say well I mean is Gosnell really
unique or have there been situations
like this in other clinics across the
country and if you investigate that
you're going to discover no Gosnell is
not unique in fact now he might be on
the more on the more severe end of the
spectrum but in terms of unsanitary
unclean just horrific ly disgusting
environments at abortion clinics you you
find that across the country that is not
unusual as well as by the way babies
being killed after after being born
alive that is also not unusual so a
person who takes note of that fact may
begin to understand that abortion is a
fundamentally dirty unsafe violent
gruesome thing and you can't change that
fact by making it legal so that's one
reason why the case is ignored number
two on a political level it is
impossible to report on this story
without implicating the Democrat Party
Philadelphia is a city run by Democrats
and it was in that Democrat run City
that a serial killer was able to operate
his Enterprise for 30 years without
interference I mean all you needed to do
was walk inside the building to see that
something was terribly wrong from all
the reports that we've heard all the
witnesses all the people that worked
there all you had to do was walk inside
and you could see that something was
very wrong
and if you actually walk past the lobby
into back where these things were
happening you would see dead humans in
buckets and in jars and you would see
all this stuff yet somehow city and
state officials didn't notice for 30
years or they did notice and they chose
to look the other way and I think
clearly that's what happened because
either either this either this clinic
was completely unregulated nobody
checked on its allegedly a medical
clinic no regulation no checking on it
nothing no oversight 0 for 30 years or
there was some oversight there was some
regulation and those people chose to
look the other way and so actually
participated in a cover-up I mean if the
media had actually been interested in
doing its job and again this is why I
didn't want to do its job here but if it
if it actually had decided to do its job
and and and really dig into this and
find out who knew about this this was
not happening on an island there was
obviously a cover-up going on there were
people in the government who had to know
about it had to and chose to not do
anything about it so how deep did that
go well we never found out because they
ignore the story but I think the third
thing most important the most
fundamental reason the most kind of
visceral reason why this story is
ignored is because this is abortion I
mean this is what Gosnell was doing is
abortion it that's all yeah he was doing
it when the babies were born as opposed
to right before they were born but this
is abortion for all of the pretending
that there is some dramatic difference
between regular old murder and abortion
when it comes down to it of course
killing an innocent helpless human is
killing an innocent helpless human
murder is murder is murder is murder
after all what is what exactly is the
substantive difference between killing a
baby moments after it leaves the birth
canal
and killing it moments before you know
you've got a baby who just emerged from
the birth canal the doctor is holding
the child
we're wine the clock you know a few
seconds what and then you know if you're
aligned the clock and then fast forward
you go back what is in-between the
emergence from the birth Kara what is
happening in that so it's it's a human
being you know as soon as it comes out
it's a human being a you know a person a
human being deserving of Rights and
dignity and all that kind of stuff and
right before that it has none well what
exactly is have what magical mystical
thing is happening as the baby comes out
of the birth canal to change to
fundamentally change it from a from a
worthless pointless blob of of lifeless
tissue to a human being I mean what
exactly is happening well the answer is
nothing the difference between the two
is simply Geographic the difference is
location and that's what it comes down
to I think the proponent of abortion
sees the Gosnell case and and thinks
yeah I mean I guess that's really not
too different is it and he knows that
and so he looks away and he turns away
and he ignores and he doesn't want to
dwell on it he doesn't want to see
abortion for what it is and he doesn't
want us to see you know I'm very glad
that Kermit Gosnell is in prison for the
rest of his life that's what he deserves
she probably deserves something even
worse than that he certainly deserves
something even worse than that I should
say but at the same time you know at the
same
I'm the argument that he made in his
defense was that was a pretty good
argument his argument was well I was
just performing abortions which are
legal I'm no different from any other
abortionist and you know something he's
right and that's and that's really why
why the left doesn't want us talking
about Goss now because they know that
he's right that he's really no different
from any other you go to any any average
Planned Parenthood you go to any any
abortion clinic and the abortionist
there they're no different from Gosnell
yeah Gosnell was it was more unorthodox
in his approach he didn't care as much
about hygiene and and and being sanitary
but when it comes down to it they're
both killing babies for a living and
they both know that that's what they're
doing and I think that's why Gosnell
didn't care you know for him he wasn't
the baby comes out he kills the baby
didn't matter to him he'd already signed
on to killing babies he does it every
day that's what he's in this way he did
it every day for 30 years made no
different he knows that there's no
difference and let me tell you something
every abortionist knows it because these
people although they are not legitimate
doctors at all they're the opposite
they're literally the opposite of
doctors doctors take the Hippocratic
oath do no harm and all they do is harm
that's their whole that's their whole
life that's what they've dedicated their
life to harming children but they do
have medical training and they do have
scientific medical knowledge and so they
know they absolutely know that what
Gosnell did is no different from what
they do it is exactly the same which is
why every abortionist should be locked
in a prison cell and that's simply an
observation and a conversation that
pro-abortion people don't want to have
and so they just ignore it it's you know
there's nothing that's that's that's the
incredible thing with Gosnell in this
whole time it's like it's not like the
left ever came up
with some narrative to explain away
Gosnell it's not like they know they
just ignored it they knew and they know
now there's nothing they can say in
defense they know that this case is bad
for them and for their whole worldview
their whole philosophy their ideology
everything they know it's terrible for
them and so they just say nothing about
these are the people that say everything
that I've done have something to say
about everything on this case they just
say nothing
that's how terrified they are of it and
that's why you should go out and support
the movie if you haven't yet thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed